hello everyone and welcome to today's
presentation Pro quantum high
sensitivity immunoassays offer minimum
sample consumption with maximum
performance it is presented by David
Borden PhD the senior R&D manager and
immunoassay strategy lead in the
Biosciences Division at Thermo Fisher
Scientific I am Judy O'Rourke of levers
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots and sponsored by thermo Fisher
Scientific for more information about
our sponsor visit
www.tbkcreative.com/eguide/casl window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Borden I will now turn the presentation
over to him
hi everyone thank you Judy and thank you
everyone for joining to learn about our
new amino acid technology as a brief
introduction I've been with thermo
Fisher Scientific since 2009 focusing on
biomarker discovery and validation
platforms
I lead a talented team of R&D scientists
here in Carlsbad California that had
developed the acid technology I'll be
sharing with you today I'm very excited
to present the pro quantum high
sensitivity immunizing platform which
was spearheaded several years ago out of
our passion to improve protein
quantification tools to address unmet
needs for immunoassay users like
yourselves the collaborative spirit and
application of user centered innovation
across Thermo Fisher Scientific enables
us to deliver these powerful
technologies to scientists like yourself
my goal is by the end of this
presentation you'll be eager to test out
the put quantum immunoassay platform for
your specific work now with that let's
go ahead and get started let me click on
the slide to Thermo Fisher Scientific
offers a wide selection of research
tools for the study of inflammation
autoimmunity and cancer for today's talk
I will be focusing on detection of
circulating cytokines and growth factors
but this technology will apply to other
types of analytes as our menu continues
to expand making sense of the
complexities of the immune system
requires scientists use the right tool
at the right time and that's the key
here weather is the one of our powerful
and unique flow cytometry or microscopy
solutions or our comprehensive I Western
workflow or our large collection of
antibodies and amino acids now for this
last group which is my focus area
immunoassays we already offer a large
selection of eliza's of Luminex bead
based assays however there is definitely
still more room for advancement and so
what I'd like to do right here is go
through the areas of biomarker discovery
do validation workflows and there are
three distinct needs
first of all for the discovery stage hi
flexing solution such as mass spec
systems enable identification of
thousands of proteins from a small
number of samples now as one seeks to
verify biomarkers and a larger sample
cohort while reducing the number of
potential candidate analytes we offered
luminex beam based assays as well as
other assets that actually can go up to
as high as 65 Plex now depending upon
the target somewhere between
verification and validation scientists
may also want to run Western blots or
imaging to verify protein expression
trafficking patterns or localization
with other targets of interest now for
today's talk I'll be focusing on the
power of the validation space we've set
out to develop a platform that could
provide rapid sample to answer consume
little of your precious samples that
typically come from undoable resources
provide those better performance be
amenable to high-throughput screening as
many validation studies involve hundreds
or thousands of samples and finally be
something that everyone can afford
now so I applied for I'd like to
introduce what we've developed Pro
quantum for quantum combines the best of
both worlds and is a fusion of mash
antibody pair specificity and the
sensitivity and broad dynamic range of
qpcr Pro quantum offers the great
sensitivity or greater sensitivity than
traditional in your assays using a
fraction of example that you're
accustomed to you having to use for
multiple replicates now in the case of
pro quantum - microliters of samples
enough to run up to 10 replicate
measurements the small volume
homogeneous at a format means minimized
assay handling no wash steps and little
generated waste which is especially
important for those individuals working
with potentially infectious sample types
a broad dynamic range helps eliminate
the need to rerun assays because your
sample didn't land on the standard curve
the first time additionally wouldn't it
be nice if you could adopt the next gen
amino acid technology without having to
allocate research dollars for purchase
of an expensive single application in
other words closed system instrument for
quantum assays can be run on any
existing real time PCR instrument that
you or your colleagues may already have
in your lab
and finally this is a passion of mine is
finally after a considerable feedback
from scientists across the globe we set
out to develop our own cloud-based for
quantum software a desktop version of
this software will be available shortly
for those who are interested and later
in the talk I'll be providing a live
demo of the software so with that let's
go ahead and talk more about the
principles behind Pro quantum what you
see here in the upper left corner slide
is basically two antibodies each
attached to a blue ribbon and a yellow
or orange ribbon and that signifies
basically a 60 mer and 440 mer all ago
so these antibodies the two different
epitopes specific antibodies are each
conjugated to a 60 ml or a 40 mer and
what happens in pro quantum is as those
two analyze specific antibodies epitope
specific bind to the analytes
simultaneously what happens is that
binding more or less stabilizes the
interaction of those ala goes with a
splint all ago and in the presence of
DNA ligase the splint all ago and the
ligase basically lead to the creation of
a 100 base pair DNA amplification
template now in the interest of time I'm
not going to go through the basics of
qpcr or real-time pcr but you can
appreciate that basically as the amount
of analyte in your sample increases the
number of binding events of course
increase and thus the number of template
molecules that are created increases
which means that the number of cycles
the reach threshold decreases and what
you see on the far right in our IP 10
assay is a classic example of a sigmoid
oil concentration response curve that
can be fitted to four PL 5 PL nonlinear
regression now next in slide 6 here I'd
like to go through the assay format how
many tubes there are what we've really
tried to focus on is making this assay
very easy to use very easy to set up and
that starts with minimizing the number
of tubes in the kit
we tried to combine as many things as
possible and so basically what you see
here on the left side is a picture of
the kit and on the right hand side is
cartoon of the various components we
include two vials of protein standard
these are lie off alized
proteins a bottle of assay dilution
buffer a two for antibody conjugate a
and antibody conjugate B those are the
two epitope specific analyte specific
antibodies and then the antibody
conjugate dilution buffer which I'll
show you in just a minute how that is
used and then on the right hand side is
a master mix actually it is a super
master mix because there are many
components in there all combined and
then separately is a DNA ligase and what
I show below the cartoon is what
components are combined by the user
before the assays run now what I'd like
to go through next is basically the
workflow and just how it compares to
other technologies out there and I'm
using Eliza the comparison example now
your Eliza may have more or less washed
steps I may have different timing but we
get the gist here with this comparison
so basically Pro quantum is a two-step
process the first step is analyte
binding and the second step is basically
glycation and qPCR now what I've shown
below are in red are 5 microliters 5
microliters and 40 microliters for
today's explanation or today's webinar
I'm going to be going through basically
the 5 micro liter reaction but what
we've tried to do with pro quantum is
basically make this a very flexible
assay so that the user only needs to buy
one kit we all hate if we decide we want
to do something a little bit different
with our assay that we have to buy an
entirely new catalog number so what
we've done is we've basically made one
catalog number that can work at the 5
micro liter scale the 2 micro liter or
the 1 microliter the reason for that is
people that are new to an amino acid
technology may not be comfortable
pipetting 2 or 1 microliter so
always is we decided to make the piace
work at the five microliter range but
once the user becomes more comfortable
with the assay they can drop it down to
two microliters and actually get two
plates worth out of the kit and for
those individuals who want to work in
the high throughput space those in
pharma biotech those that are automation
liquid handling enthusiasts this assay
will also work in high-throughput
screening now in all cases this assay
again as mentioned previously is
compatible with any qPCR instrument in
the case of thermo Fisher scientific
instruments that's in the form of a dot
EDF file that is imported directly but
if you are the owner of another
manufacturers qPCR instrument all you
have to do is present the data to the
pro quantum app in the form of a dot CSV
file and I'll actually be going through
the cloud app more in just a minute so
let's go through now next in more detail
how you actually set up the assay so of
course the first thing we do is take the
kid out of the freezer
father reagents and follow the
directions placing them on ice the first
thing you do is actually reconstitute
the lyophilized protein standard all the
directions with the amount and method
etc and wait for 15 minutes and by the
way we do have a video on our website
that provides more detail if this
webinar doesn't provide enough detail so
after you reconstitute the protein you
let it sit for 15 minutes give that time
for the protein to rehydrate ensure
proper folding of a protein during that
time the user can then go ahead and
create a setup plate and how I compare
or equate a setup plate is basically
setting the dinner table before you have
a meal and all joking aside what it does
is you know it makes the experience a
little bit nicer and more organized and
that's what the setup plate does for pro
quantum not only does it help keep you
organized but it also ensures that
you're diluted samples remain cold we
know that your samples and the analytes
in those samples can be
quite labile so we want to ensure that
everything stays cold however trying to
keep a qpcr plate in an ice bucket we've
all been there where ice chips get into
the welds it creates a lot of
frustration so basically just using a
aluminum cold block can take away all
those frustrations and then finally the
setup plate what it does is it enables
multi-channel type heading and that's a
really important one here because I
think once you see how we run our asses
you may apply this approach to other
assays you run it really does make it a
lot easier so the first thing that user
does is go ahead and combine volumes of
their antibody conjugate a B and the
dilution buffer in a microfuge tube mix
and equally distribute through eight
wells in this case a 1 through h1 after
that's completed then the user will go
ahead and dilute their samples our
delusions are anywhere from 10% to 30%
and that depends on the assay and you
just need to follow the directions in
the protocol so after you dilute your
samples probably 15 minutes has gone by
and that means that your recombinant
protein is ready for a procreation of a
standard curve so it's a classic serial
dilution like any other assay and you
place that on the right hand side of the
plate so what you see here is you've got
three separate parts of your assay all
separated out but notice that they are
all in the format in this case of a
channel multi-channel pipettor and
that's because the next step basically
all you have to do is take your setup
plate take a multi-channel type header
first populate the antibody conjugates
to the assay plate and by the lady as
they played at the plate that will go
into qPCR instrument first you populate
the antibody conjugates on the plate and
then you follow up with either the
standards and how many other replicates
you choose to run and then the unknown
samples mix and let that incubate for
one hour now again what I'd like to
point out here is again so far you've
seen no wash steps
so after the one hour basically you with
about let's say five minutes before the
end of your one hour incubation you
combine your master mix ligase mix and
then apply that right on top of the
assay plate so again there's no washing
no removal of anything you just add the
master mix and ligase on top at that
point in time you go ahead and place the
plate in the qPCR instrument at which
point the ligation occurs and then
immediately following 40 cycles of
real-time PCR or tack man qPCR now in
slide 10 here I'd like to go ahead and
show just some example traces of
standard curves comparing Pro quantum -
Eliza's and in some cases they're a
ultra-sensitive eliza's or not on what
you see here is again the demonstration
of a very broad dynamic range which then
in this case also leads to greater
sensitivity i've list some of the assay
characteristics in the bottom right
corner we test for spike recovery in
serum plasma of course we do linearity
of dilution parallelism enter and enter
a say CV we look at specificity cross
reactivity and then most important we
benchmark - Eliza's and perform ni BSC
calibration the benchmarking - Eliza's
really important as you're switching
from an existing technology to something
new to this day Eliza's still the gold
standard and what you'll see here in
this next slide is what we've done is
basically either screened diseased human
serum samples and/or PBMC supernatants
now we tested them on both platforms
Eliza and Pro quantum that's important
to note here to be able to benchmark one
assay with another if the sensitivity is
not comparable in some cases we actually
have to supplement we have to supplement
small amounts of these analytes with PD
NC suits just to get enough data points
to
pair so if it's undetectable on Eliza
then we use the PBM see super names but
what you can see here is a number of
different analytes and by the way these
human zero samples are from our
collection is a lot of rheumatoid
arthritis Crohn's disease lupus we focus
on autoimmunity and various forms of
inflammation and what you can see here
across a number of different analytes
there's great concordance and we what
you see here also is the slopes are more
or less one and that's because what
we've done is we've calibrated our pro
Kuantan assays to those reading Eliza's
to ensure that people are comfortable
with the transition from analyzer to pro
quantum now let me dive into a little
more detail on a couple aspects I
mentioned earlier in the talk that this
technology is scaleable and then you can
perform at five two or one microliter
but of course you know that's a great
claim but you want to see the data so
what we've done here is actually dump I
a person on my team and we took an assay
annihilate assay and actually performed
it manually there's no automated liquid
handling involved here it's all manual
pipetting the operator went ahead and
performed a five micro liter assay a two
micro liter or a one microliter all by
hand same day same time and what you can
see here is the results are very
comfortable now to individuals who are
more accustomed to plate based assays
where there is a capture antibody on the
surface of the plate scalability is a
different story because of course when
you are trying to capture an analyte you
have to worry about having at least the
minimum amount of volume to coat the
surface of the plate the the mixing time
the mixing temperature possibly the
velocity of the mixing all of those
things can play a role in making sure
that a plate based assay that's on a
solid phase is performed reproducibly
correctly and gives
great results every time but the beauty
of poor quantum is it's a homogeneous
tacit long things are mixed just like
any standard good pipetting practice it
works every time and that's because it's
all homogeneous everything's in solution
and it's scalable and of course qPCR is
very scalable too so what you see here
on the far right overlay is basically
the exact same performance whether it be
the 5 micro liter volume down to the 1
micro litre volume now next what I'd
like to go into a little bit more about
the flexibility of the SI individuals
who are listening to this webinar who
have other platforms right now where
let's say the platform can read it
doesn't go plates because there's a
stacker or something they might look at
this and say wait a second you know I've
only got one qPCR instrument how am I
going to run dozens of plates and we do
have a solution for that one as well and
it's actually a very simple and clever
solution so let's just follow along here
so we've pretend that you ran 10 plates
it can be 10 20 30 but let's say you ran
10 plates so you perform 10 plates where
you perform your one hour incubation um
what you do then is you add your master
mix and ligase but you know what instead
of ligating in a qpcr instrument let's
just go ahead and place all those sealed
plates in a temperature-controlled
incubator for 20 minutes now again
everything is sealed
there's no problem here so 20 minutes 25
degrees and then instead of doing
instrument based inactivation at 95
degrees why not just use a water bath at
95 degrees again the plates are sealed
nothing's going to get into them all you
have to do is basically float that plate
on top of the 95 degree water bath you
can do them all at the same time and now
what you've done is you have basically
frozen everything in time so now the
analyte the antibodies all the other
proteins everything is denatured
everything has been activated the ligase
has been inactivated because you know
what at this point it doesn't matter
it's all a DNA readout at this point so
what you can do is store those plates
until you're ready to read them and a
lot of people who have our qpcr systems
actually have stackers attached to our
quants to do instruments so you can
actually read these out later and one
nice benefit is that once the plate is
inactivated it's actually more stable
than other platforms where there may be
stackers involved but you're still under
a time dependency because things are not
inactivated things are still happening
in those plates in this case it's just a
DNA readout and that can be done same
day next day or even days later now to
answer that question of really how long
can you go how robust is this we perform
the following experiment what we did is
we perform aisle 12 P 40 assays on known
samples pooled human sera or individual
donors with known amounts of violet or P
40 so we ran a series of assays in this
case we ran four plates we ran
everything on on day zero we went ahead
and performed a 1-hour incubation the
incubator based
I'm spurting the incubator based
ligation and then the inactivation in
the water bath so then we will go ahead
and just store the plaits in the
refrigerator for up to 14 days and read
them on various days and then calculate
it or interpolated the concentration of
the analyte off the standard curves that
will run on each plate on each day and
what you can see here is there we get
great CDs even after 14 days and so with
a take-home point here is that once
you've inactivated your plates you can
let them go as long as you want because
again it's DNA and it's very stable so
the next thing I'd like to talk about
real briefly is some other benefits of
the pro quantum kit one thing that as an
amino acid developer I've always been
very concerned about when you label an
antibody what actually happens to it
when you're attaching a various tag or
label to it do you know where it's going
and the case of pro quantum because it's
such a sensitive assay platform you can
detect very little changes in antibody
quality and so what we wanted to do is
make sure that when we label antibodies
we are not jeopardizing or or
compromising the performance of the
variable domains so what we did is we
use cyclic chemistry and what cyclic is
that's basically an enzymatic labeling
chemistry that we we provide and we are
able to target the glycosylation sites
in the heavy chains of IgG s and so what
we do here is we can have anywhere
between 1 & 4 by atoms but we basically
have optimized the reaction to have
between 3 & 4 by atoms per i GG and of
course these streptavidin eligos are
attached to the biotinylated antibody
now 3 to 4 biotin is per IgG may not
sound like a lot for those of you out
there that work and flow in imaging you
may say wow that doesn't seem like a lot
but you know what again it doesn't
matter because we're using tech man
amplification what I'm showing here on
the left side is a series of bottom left
corner pardon me
is a series of labeling reactions in
which we have determined the degree of
labeling of biotin on an IgG using a non
specific labeling chemistry in blue and
in red you see the cyclic chemistry so
the number of biotin is per molecule of
IgG
in the nonspecific can range in this
assay and you are between two and ten
actually if you proteolytically digest
the IgG the number of biotin can
actually go up much higher fifteen or
twenty that just shows you that the
biotin is can sometimes get buried in
the IgG molecule but with cyclic
chemistry it's very consistent and very
tight because it's limited by that
entomology that is in the upper left
corner in that cartoon you can only have
four buttons at most now in this bottom
left panel here what we did also is we
took those particular antibodies and
made for quantum PLA probes out of them
and then ran various concentration
response curves and what you can see
here is that again if you're using site
click you get a very tight reproducible
result across replicate standard curves
so each standard curve is from a
different biotin elation set whereas the
nonspecific labeling some times you can
get something that really performs
poorly sometimes mediocre etc so the
point here is that you have inconsistent
results so the reason we provide cyclic
chemistry with you is that it ensures
reproducibility but also for those
individuals that are really concerned
about specificity and their variable
domains of the antibodies you can rest
assured that we're using a labeling
chemistry that will never impact that
now with the remaining on a climb I'd
like to go through our cloud at this
slide here slide 16 just kind of gives a
high-level screenshot of some of the
various steps in the assay again we
started from scratch from the ground up
building our own cloud based app and by
the way again there is a desktop app
those that are interested as well but we
built up from the ground up because
myself and and my colleagues you know
over the years we've seen some
interesting software packages but many
of them left room for improvement and
they just didn't do what we wanted so
given that Thermo Fisher Scientific has
a an amazing cloud computing initiative
a lot of people are already using it and
love it we decided to capitalize on that
and make our own cloud app what you see
here are various screenshots and I'll go
through more of this in just a minute
but our app has a wizard for the
standard curve set up setting up your
plate customized lab instructions is
something I'll go through in just a
minute but this is pretty cool because
what it does is it takes all of those
notes that you might have to customize
for a specific experiment and what's in
the plate and where it is on the plate
and all that and basically captures all
that for you it's in a PDF could be
printed out put in an electronic lab
notebook but basically we've streamlined
all of that so you don't have to sit
there and basically make copies of the
product insert that you may have which
is in many cases a little booklet we
want to stay away from booklets you'll
see our documentation is very short and
sweet and you can then put that in your
notebook next sample concentrations
you'll see more detail about how we
present the data to you and then finally
I wanted to show GroupWise comparison we
have a modified mann-whitney GroupWise
comparison based on M stats and that
allows us to make some very powerful
comparisons with various groups because
many of you that are in the
translational research space will
appreciate that a patient populations or
human subject populations are very
heterogeneous and so that there's a lot
of difference between individual so
having statistical software that can
actually decipher some of that is
important and then in the bottom right
corner I'm just calling out some of the
things I've already mentioned but again
just to remind everyone that this
platform is compatible with any
real-time PCR insert and then
little kid then I'll show that or just
make mention of it is over the years
ever since grad school I've loved graph
pad software and we actually have a
quick way for you to create your own
graph pad data files to to ease that
process as well so with that let's go
ahead and get started I'll go ahead and
switch screens here so just bear with me
just for a second
okay so you should be able to see my
screen now let me switch over to the
browser
you'll see here when you first enter the
pro contem app are these two large blue
rectangles the one on the Left says
create experiment belong on the right
says import and view results now if
you're new to the platform what you'll
see is pardon if you're new to the
platform what you'll see is basically an
empty spot down here where it says
recent but once you come back to the
application again and again your recent
files your recent runs will appear down
here as well so for this demo I cleared
everything out of my cloud app account
and let's just start fresh here as
though you would new to the platform so
let's go ahead and click get started the
first thing you'll see here is an
opportunity for you to type in the
catalogue number and that's kind of nice
because I'll just paste an assay here
today we're going to focus on the mCP 3
assay but you see as soon as you enter
the catalog number it provides the
species and the light and the stock
concentration um as well as the
recommended s1 concentration for the
assay so the user can go ahead and
populate the lot number let's just type
in Australian numbers here but what this
is nice for is if you want to track your
lot numbers that's also captured
throughout the essay process through the
software process so later on when you're
looking at your data you can see what
lot number you are using the user can go
ahead and adjust the deletions
the rate of dilution if you go ahead and
choose more than seven data points the
working plate and by the way on the
right hand side here is sort of a
cartoon of what the working plate is
going to look like it switches to a
horizontal position so that it makes it
easier so you would use in this case a
twelve channel type header multi-channel
to perform the transfer to the assay
plate but in this example we're just
going to switch to a seven-point curve
fivefold solution
in this case we're actually going to
look at a data set from a benchmarking
study and we actually ran duplicates on
this particular experiment and we
started the s-1 concentration at 1000
now if everything looks fine to the user
then you click Next and what you see
here is it automatically puts the
standard curve on the left side however
if you do want it in different spot on
the plate that's fine and as I'll show
you in just a minute we have those lab
instructions will then explain to you
the user and remind them by the way you
move the standard curve somewhere else
so it's a customized lab instruction but
for this specific example we'll stick
with the default in this experiment we
ran 30 samples in duplicate and what you
can do here is now go through and assign
different groups and this will be really
important because what you can see here
is
you can do anything with the plate
layout you can change things around you
can actually give it a different name
you can go ahead and assign different
names you can assign different colors
for all of this because later on you're
going to have data that you want to
publish you want to take it somewhere
else and it's nice to be able to
annotate everything right away you can
actually also add descriptions and all
this can be seen in more detail on our
training video but if this looks okay we
can go ahead and move forward oh you
know what I just forgot there's one more
thing I wanted to show you guys what you
can see here is you know if you wanted
to do a manual setup where let's say
this is fine and dandy that you have a
default but you know what a lot of
people scientists we'd love to customize
things and make things exactly the way
we want them and where we were going
with this was you know what if you want
to add more samples let's say you want
to skip these wells here and now you
want to do some unknowns here Wow if you
want to do a manual setup clicking each
of these and assigning them one at a
time would be very laborious so what we
did is we applied sort of a
click-and-drag feature similar to an
autofill on excel so if you've got one
set of unknowns for example in this case
already defined all you have to do is
click and drag and then it auto fills
for you so again that's just a and by
the way that works in horizontal or
vertical and we're adding more features
like that all the time that's another
beauty of cloud applications is that you
can really customize them on the fly and
very quickly so let me just undo that
for this particular experiment so
everything looks great we move on to the
next okay so at this point it's
prompting me to go ahead and save the
file save the plate layout I'm just
going to call it mCP 3
bench benchmarking
okay so right now is saving the file
name or saving the plate layout next
what it's going to show you here are the
customized lab instructions
and now what you see is it goes through
every single step just like I said at
the beginning of this talk you till your
reagents you constitute your standard up
here it also prompts you whether you
want the 5 micro liter or the 2 micro
liter acid it prompts whether you want a
fast block or standard block that will
dictate the cycle times if I scroll down
here you'll see that it goes through
each of the steps that I talked through
earlier about how to make a working
plate create a standard curve all of
this information that we went through is
captured on this one screen and here's
your customized plate layout and then
down here is providing instructions on
how to run the qpcr instrument so again
this is all captured it can be printed
out it can be saved as a PDF very
convenient
now the user goes off runs the
experiment
and then collects a data file
and so now what you're going to see here
is a prompt to either upload the data
file from the cloud or import it from
your computer now if you are an owner of
one of our qs3 rqs five instruments
that's already connected to the cloud
your VBS files are already present in
your account and and ready to go now in
this case I'm going to just show you how
you import from your own
I select the mCP 3 file and now it's
prompting me to pick the plate layout
that I just defined and in this case
here's the mCP 3 bench
file that I created and now what's
happening is the cloud app is applying
the settings from before and so what you
see here and you know what we've all
been in the case where we were at the
bench we planned our experiment but then
things change either some samples can't
be found or your supervisor comes up and
says hey you know what let's try
something different so there's always
need to be able to adjust later so what
we do is we give the user one more
opportunity to verify that the standard
curve is still the way they intended on
running it but the plate layout is still
the way they wanted to run it and now if
everything checks out the software is
applying the four PL or 5 PL regression
to the data that I had uploaded and what
you'll see in just a moment is a
standard curve it's important to note
here as you're seeing this little
spinning wheel that you do need to have
a good internet connection as well as
probably have the amount of recommended
RAM in your computer and so as we go
here there we go you'll see the first
presence of the standard curves
and we're at this screen you'll be able
to apply outlier filters various various
ways to look at the data you can
actually go through and also look at it
in table format you can actually go
through and look at the amplification
spots that's really important for power
users in the qPCR world they very
accustomed to looking at their at their
amplification plots and by the way we
now have in our software the ability to
change the threshold it's important to
note here that we recommend a point to
threshold that's these florescent
threshold point - to determine the CT
values however in your various qpcr
instrument whether or not it's been
calibrated recently or not etc you may
need to adjust that threshold and we
provide opportunity or a method for you
to adjust the threshold Dakota ideally
the threshold should be in the linear
part of an amplification it should not
be too high or too low okay so if if
everything checks out you click Next and
now it's basically solidifying those
settings or the standard curve and now
what you'll see here and the reason why
I had defined those groups previously
was because you can see here they show
up in different spots on the standard
curve so what we have here is we had
basically three different groups and the
group here in green was known to express
less amount of mCP 3 than the other
groups and so what that allows you to do
and the subsequent screen which I'll
show you just a minute is the group wise
comparison but before we move to that I
just want to show you that there are
different views you can choose you can
change the format of the X and y-axis
you can look at replicates or average
also you can go in here and here's where
you can export to graphpad prism you can
create an excel file export you can also
create a PDF version report out which
includes even a heatmap
of the data points and the interpolated
analyte concentrations
what I'd like to show here is that
GroupWise comparison and the calculated
key values with that so in the interest
of time I think that's been enough to
show the cloud app it's quite nimble
it's easy to use and it's available to
everyone so let me go ahead and switch
back to
to the bus
to wrap this up
you know the pro quantum assay enables
new possibilities it does allow you to
measure proteins in these very small
volumes that you might not have been
able to measure previously the workflow
is easy hopefully you've come away from
this appreciating that it is a rapid
sample that to answer it's two hours the
cloud app is easy to use and hopefully
you'll see that this assay platform can
provide many new opportunities for you
and your team lastly I'd like to just
show a series of analytes that we've
already got on the market
you'll see that our mouse analytes look
a little sparse right now but for those
of you that are in the mouse research
field please don't worry we are we are
working eagerly on on creating more
assays in the mouse field as well in the
mouse analyte realm so more to come in
the future on that and finally let me
just say that I want to acknowledge the
contributions from my local calls bad
team as well as the extended teams
around the world we're a global
organization we have teammates as far as
Vienna Austria and closer to home and
it's I'm very appreciative of all of the
work and contributions from all of us
it's been a real team effort a lot of
satisfaction and we look forward to
continuing to hear the feedback from
users like yourself to make this sa
platform even better and so with that I
am ready to take any questions thank you
very much
of presentation we will now start the
live Q&A portion of the webinar if you
have a question you'd like to ask please
do so now just click on the ask a
question drop-down box located on the
far left of your presentation window
type your question into the box that
appears on your screen
and click the send button will answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for let's get started first question is
do you provide custom service to develop
a specific target that I am interested
in that's a very good question thank you
very much I'm actually at this point in
time we do not offer a custom service
however please let me say that don't let
that stop you from communicating to us
either through your account manager or
reaching out directly on our website um
or even to myself even even through
LinkedIn whatever we definitely want to
hear from you we want to hear what
targets you'd like to see next on this
platform thank you next one is is it
possible to get ligation of the three
prime and five prime all ago in the
absence of antigen that's a very good
question I so for those of you listen to
this and may be very accustomed to tech
man genomic readout assays you might
look at that
the data that we've provided today and
say wait a second my no template control
or my background is around 38 CT and
David what you're showing us is around
32 or 33 that difference right there is
a difference in background and long
story short when you take the tak man
Allah goes and and attach them to 160
kilo Dalton IgG s you will have more
background that you would in a typical
genomic assay the key take-home here
though however is that we can still
distinguish signal from noise and so you
can still see a very large dynamic range
a very distinguishable sense
and selectivity so you will see some
some background but that's just because
we are attaching these cap nano goes to
such large IG G's but again it does not
affect the assay and the robustness of
the assay
thank you next one is canis sa be
multiplexed
yeah you know that's it for those of you
who have followed in the literature and
for those of you who know about tack man
technology um you can see that if you do
have multiple eligos on multiple
antibodies um that is something that can
be achieved in the literature various
groups have done various extent of
expanding the single Plex right now for
quantum is designed as a single Plex
platform um but definitely we want to
hear from users like yourself as to
whether that is something you would like
to see expanded upon very good I would
like to once again thank dr. Borden for
his presentation would also like to
thank Thermo Fisher Scientific for
making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through September of 2019 please share
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that is all for now
thank you for joining us we hope to see
you again soon goodbye